so earlier this week we kind of hit oan
pretty hard
because they deserve it oan is this
wacky right-wing propaganda network and
i i think i said in the segment fox news
is right-wing propaganda
news max is extreme right-wing
propaganda and oan is like completely
insane right-wing propaganda and i even
said
compared to oan
newsmax sometimes will sound sort of a
little bit reasonable today i have an
example of newsmax not sounding even at
all reasonable and this is a really
instructive segment i'm going to play
for you one of the most hilariously and
horrifyingly
ignorant segments that i've ever seen i
would say on any network i i don't know
that i've ever seen
a one minute segment with such ignorance
there's a news max host named chris
salcedo salcido
i actually think i've been on his show
before i work if i'm thinking of the
same guy he used to have a radio show
maybe philly i don't remember
i think the interview i did with him on
his radio show might even be on our
website in the press section from what i
recall
he was much less ignorant back then the
ignorance was less weaponized although
it was still bad i don't know if what
i'm about to play for you are his
genuine views or what he has to do to be
on the good boy list at oan but he went
on a rant yesterday climate change
denial rant
i can't make heads or tails out of it
i don't know how someone can be this
dumb and again he might not be dumb this
might just be over propaganda it's like
brain rot of some kind like his his head
is filled with mayonnaise or
honey mustard or something it's almost
like his brain fell out of his head so
let me play the clip
listen to the mind-blowingly ignorant
and incorrect things that he says here
and then we're going to break it down
piece by piece as to the science of the
socialist religion
from experts i have read and interviewed
over the years i can say that there is
no proof that man's co2 emissions are
destroying the planet if that were the
case the world would have invaded
communist china long ago they build one
so-called dirty coal-fired plant on
average every week
if china's co2 emissions were destroying
all life on mother earth and china is
the world's number one co2 emitter
why would obama biden and the rest of
the american left leave china alone and
instead destroy the united states
manufacturing base and our energy
production
joe biden claims that warmer
temperatures make weather more
destructive that has not been proven
what has been proven is that warmer
weather results in more food production
less starvation and less death
what has been proven is that the earth
has been at this temperature before back
in the medieval period not too many coal
plants and suvs trolling around at that
time right
so you you really have to
slow down
and think about each aspect of this one
at a time
the mind-blowing stupidity
is notable
but the wildest aspect is he almost
seems like proud that he's saying this
stuff on tv
he genuinely seems to think it's clever
so let's go through it piece by piece
he talks about science the socialists
religion
you can make the case that sometimes
people
allow
dogmatism
to enter their view of science and when
that happens we should criticize it
but science is not a religion and when
when people say science is your religion
you can believe in christianity or you
can believe in science that's very much
wrong because science exists and is the
same regardless of whether you believe
in it or not nobody believed in
christianity christianity disappears
right uh science encourages being
corrected fixing mistakes and has
self-correction mechanisms and in fact
when you make the the bigger the
correction you make in science the
bigger the accolades the more revered
you are religion doesn't have that
uh self-correction is not revered in
religion
uh so
these analogies science is the religion
of socialists maybe there's some
dogmatic people when it comes to science
is very very different than a religion
he says experts that i've read and
interviewed say there's no proof that
co2 from man is destroying the planet
it's always hyperbolic and there's
always some semantic game right so okay
well destroying the planet is a big
statement the scientific consensus is
very clear
that elevated co2
caused by industrial activity now if you
would they say well humans didn't do
that the factories did it that's a
distinction without a difference
that is bad for the planet in many ways
its effect on climate
its effect on the ozone layer
accelerating the greenhouse effect this
is the scientific consensus could it be
wrong it could
many people right now are trying to
disprove it none have been able to so
far remains the best explanation we have
right now that's how science works
um he says if co2 were really this bad
we would have invaded communist china by
now you know the issue of china's
pollution is a huge topic in and of
itself and it kind of exceeds our scope
today but it is absurdly simplistic to
say if co2 were really bad we would
invade china it's so dumb it's kind of
hard to refute adults don't really think
in this way he then argues that co2
emissions
uh aren't really destroying all life on
earth
well we're not saying that that's what
it is it's sort of again that the
argument isn't all life on earth today
is being destroyed by co2 it's a straw
man or a red herring
um he argues that warmer temperatures
are good
because if it's warmer
you get more food growth
that's really complicated but understand
that when it's unseasonably warm
if you don't have more rain to go with
it you get drought and drought is not
good for crops it kills crops or you've
got to go and find more water to raise
the same amount of food that's also not
good for the environment so warmer being
better for food production also not true
uh and then he says earth has been at
this temperature before before we had
modern industry that's true there have
been periods of warming on earth before
uh but temperatures are only one part of
what's going on co2 in the atmosphere
has never been this high that's a big
piece of it the fact that it's been warm
before doesn't prove or disprove
anything so it took me what seven
minutes
this is like two plus two equals five
type of stuff and it takes a while to
disprove it uh sam harris said and on
this he's completely right
it's very easy to start a series of
small fires
that are really time consuming to put
out it's much easier to start the fires
than to put them out and unfortunately
whether chris salcedo believes this
stuff or he knows he's just feeding his
audience the drivel and pablum that they
so desperately want uh some of his
audience falls for it and believes it
and now we're sitting here trying to
undo it really really bad and i mean
it's like like his brain left his his
cranium really scary stuff uh we have a
uh we have two things going on number
one
the town hall rescheduled for december
28th due to technical difficulties 6 p.m
december 28th i hope you'll join us
it'll definitely be the last one of the
year also january 1st we'll be doing a
one-day membership bomb
kicking off an election year with a huge
membership discount i would love for you
to participate all you need to do today
is sign up for my mailing list at
davidpakman.com and then on the first
you'll be notified about exactly how to
avail yourself of this incredible
membership discount
when i've talked about my approach to
finances and investing i've talked about
how my focus is the correct asset
allocation over the long term i'm not
timing the market i'm not picking
specific stocks i'm just prioritizing
choosing the right asset allocation for
my situation diversifying properly and
just waiting and lately i've been
diversifying into fine artwork because
it's an asset class that has a low
correlation with the stock market and
it's also a rapidly growing asset class
art has also outpaced the s p by 174
from 1995 to 2020 but most people can't
afford to actually go and buy an
expensive piece of art and it gets
really complicated between insurance and
storage
you've got to be in the one percent the
alternative is investing in art through
a platform like masterworks one of our
sponsors masterworks actually acquires
blue chip art files them with the sec
and then allows investors to invest in
shares of the pieces of artwork this way
you don't need to buy an entire piece of
art and you can also trade your shares
on the secondary market without the
piece having to be sold meaning you also
don't need to find a specific buyer to
buy the entire piece of art click the
link below to skip their exclusive wait
list and start investing today